[Music]
in two colors news run right Phil
Collins
yeah submitted by this makes me feel
lonely
a woman shared how different her
boyfriend treats her in real life versus
on social media I love it I love it I
see this [ __ ] too many times he's like
super awesome in real life and in like
in social media it's like so [ __ ]
wack yeah all these stupid-ass bucks
they always comment and they see our
picture another relationship gold I'm
like you know do you know how many
fights we have every [ __ ] week every
[ __ ] day but [ __ ] they're stupid just
because I take a happy ass picture with
Tiger don't mean I love them fight we
fight Casey until fight so everyone
fights all day over stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
one time I came to their house and
[ __ ] I saw something fly out the
window is Thai can I grab him yo what
the [ __ ] title is like wow so I have to
throw him out again the other way I like
do what the [ __ ] dude why'd you catch
him David if I was like again the next
the next take was David holding Tyco and
he was really fine I saw her put your
ass on blast every time you left your
[ __ ] ring at home oh yeah I mean she
liked me fun okay that's why yeah we
fight relationship goes you guys our
relation on our side they have what we
call disagreements in minor bickerings
but they have they're not very intense
human beings I spend a lot of time with
him now they're very mellow I'm trying
to absorb what he does in my life
it's not working a lot of my fellow
people are like it's very mellow yeah
when very mellow people get together
it's just difficult for them to fight
somebody was like someone saw in the
comments like dude she seems like she
doesn't [ __ ] with you like that cuz she
doesn't really like I guess I said
something oh because I have a girl
twerking in my most recent video and I
was like and in my vlog I'm like a babe
I got a girl working on my new video is
that cool and she's like yeah just you
know pay me a fee and we're good and
then as a joke yeah and then someone
comments like dude if she did get mad
she doesn't [ __ ] with you but literally
it's because she just doesn't care
they put their own insecurities out
there all the time when they see [ __ ]
like that I'm like purposely want their
significant other to be jealous cuz
that's what that's true right it makes
them when they care about you when
they're really jealous silly okay
okay girl she posted I don't want nobody
to be jealous it's a waste of time she
posted fatness Everdeen goodnight the
fatness every day that's dope I just
find it funny how the minute the bedroom
door closes my boyfriend is like baby
hearts heart i emoji let's get the
cuddles going chugga-chugga-choo-choo
cuddle training eye emoji heart emoji
hearts stars monkey face covering ears
coming around kissing heart face kissy
heart face next stop cutie pie village
population you partially but his inste
captions are like me and [ __ ] oh so
it's exactly what yeah that's what I
thought so he's trying to act hella hard
online oh I think that's kind of common
right my hoe and then yeah the caption
is my hope so the Texans are just saying
like let me just send you some texts on
how much I appreciate you you've made me
so happy
even after everything has happened you
managed to make me feel so wanted your
smile is one of the best things in this
world and don't even get me started how
gorgeous you are oh my god this guy's a
[ __ ] thirsty [ __ ] and here he got
the girl
hey hey he's sweet it's girls like you
make sweet dudes not want to be sleep
nah yeah [ __ ] you got have a balance no
just don't be fake you say you've got me
a fake this is the office oh [ __ ]
this is what it is did she's a rough
[ __ ] woman dude she likes the dumbest
[ __ ] [ __ ] and she wants Bart to come
round it's this [ __ ] cool if you look at
their better which is blood splattering
everywhere
oh we just [ __ ] last night on you
period
absolutely not he just smashed my teeth
open she's weird
no I'm turned on [ __ ] right my [ __ ]
beta males she didn't like beta males
that's her thing I can't yeah I can't
which one would you rather have on my
hole in public and all sweet like that
in private or the other way around all
sweet in public but then you [ __ ] a
little bit my only choices yeah do you
have your cutie talk he's your papa bear
but you know about it right before but
it's both before it was private that's
what I'm saying like I guess it's not
like this but he never called me as
whole like he did we don't have too hard
you know I don't call I have my [ __ ]
[ __ ] water sound right you know what
I mean like it was it was still like
loving but you didn't know what what
extent yeah so it was it was still the
same I mean to be fair I get why this
can be too much in cornea and cringy and
annoying but also because of the content
of her big of a difference it is they
also don't know how many times you left
the toilet seat up before this taxi for
social media though like where people
are acting extra lovey on camera for the
[ __ ] views yeah but not so like
they're cold in real life that's
actually new this is actually more like
what do the overact super like oh yeah I
don't fly [ __ ] control my girl like
they're all [ __ ] cool but then when
they're with their girlfriend they're
like oh honey did you eat yeah this
we're hungry
girls huh oh this is a different girl no
they're saying that it's that girl
oh so this here it really resonated with
a lot of people because then a whole
bunch of girls started posting their own
versions of it so like the boyfriend
says hiking with my brewski high one and
get to see my baby boy falling more in
love with it today than the last always
you were the love of my life that's why
I love all these girls are putting their
guys on blast like this one is hashtag
men and then it's like hey I know you're
asleep but I love you and miss you in
Louisville the other one is like tell me
when you see the difference of these two
photos and it's like hey I miss you and
I love you so much that just goes to so
you chased home like that you guys don't
like Q I saw so I was gonna try to keep
moving I haven't been sleeping okay
alright misinterpret what I was trying
to see earlier what I mean I like that
like if a guy can be true to himself
whether he's a [ __ ] hard-ass and
that's all he knows [ __ ] like this
dude I'm the bad part but not like a
fake hard no yeah I know exactly what
you're talking about these guys yeah so
if you're gonna be that hard person be
that like just be yourself like I have
no problem if you wanted to be like he
calls me [ __ ] mom a bit you know what
I mean like he changed the art to a demo
so I stirred like I don't mind
so I have no issues with it my issue has
always just been like don't G tendencies
yeah it's what as the kids say now bring
that same energy but I also think some
of these are just um funny you know I'm
saying like like where it's like hashtag
man crush Monday before your girlfriend
like that's that's just funny if that
one's funny the other one like I say me
and my [ __ ] you know it's right come on
that's a little different but it's funny
to us because we're assuming that
there's this balance but the girls don't
find it funny cuz that's probably what
they do all the time and the girls are
like come on bro like be this guy that
text message was a caption and and then
they also had the funny like my man bro
then there's balance right but if
they're only doing it behind closed
doors then it's almost like a friend
that acts different when you're in a
group now yeah like you know when you're
younger like there's that guy that like
rags on his girlfriend or the girlfriend
that rags on their boyfriend in front of
the group but then when they're together
they're totally [ __ ] why try to act all
hard yeah so I don't mind it I think
it's cute like be be vulnerable be
whatever but just be was like that dude
let's kickin it with the girl comes in
your side yo [ __ ] give me a [ __ ]
drink or whatever [ __ ] now I'm gonna
[ __ ] what you do [ __ ] hold off so let me
talk to my [ __ ] real quick I'll get you
a story about no better side yeah but
what I will say it would suck on this
day that's so tiring it's like it's okay
like be it's alright chill out they're
going to lose that I don't know it
sounded legit oh it's alright
accept it but yeah here's a couple more
um is it Kapowski compiled about koplow
she's short as [ __ ] she's gingers [ __ ]
that's fun then happy one-year noodle
and I feel bad too because I'm like why
did the guy though why do these guys
feel like they have the front like well
on the other hand - I guess if I was
thinking about that I guess like a high
point it would be better that they are
actually affection in real life versus
being just affectionate on Instagram
being a [ __ ] in real life yeah also for
me right I feel like if I was to say the
gushy [ __ ] I say in text messages in a
caption and I read that I would feel
like that's somebody trying to put out
the image of oh my God look how cute and
loving it are it almost seems like fake
because it's so loving you know I'm
saying because so many people are fake
on social media I feel like if you're
putting all that in the caption then
it's like what are you trying to prove
you know it's interesting cuz I for me I
can't write stuff like that Muriel I
could say to her in person like my ho
and [ __ ] know like yeah I can't write
that [ __ ] but I see it was so [ __ ] no
but if I'm saying affectionate things I
can't write it out I could say it to her
face to face though
but if cuz writing it I was like yeah I
don't know yeah it seems like it's like
the most affectionate [ __ ] needs to be
the most personal yeah like I would say
like any of that stuff I could never
write that [ __ ] cuz yes wouldn't it be
weird for me like a bike is safe to her
like it when I see her after she comes
from work I could say all this yeah it's
like if you have wedding vows you say it
in person you're not gonna text the
wedding vows people tend to read their
way - yeah that's still in person I see
I feel like the depending on the medium
it's like the more in person the more
personal should be versus like the
goosey goosey goosey goosey goosey
should be personal to be a more
important to be more in person
what am i right just mispronouncing
things more easily than goe today oh
you're way more right something wrong to
Muriel is where I'm yelling at what I'm
angry
yeah I mean are you [ __ ] ki ask your
mother [ __ ] it might you talk to me like
that you longer this thing but yes and
then how many ducks do you write that
you have to change back to hunt so you
get out anyways you must be ducking out
of your duck in mind because what the
duck bench you [ __ ] shut I'm tired of
your shot oh she's like dude are you
drunk
what's going on
[Music]